[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
wie versprochen das rezept meiner
sachertorte diese sachertorte ist
unglaublich schokoladig und das gute ist
ihr könnt sie einige tage im voraus zu
bereiten denn sie bleibt tagelang saftig
wir fangen zuallererst an mit dem
schokoladen teig wir benötigen ja ja die
habe ich in eigelb und eiweiß getrennt
außerdem zucker mehl bacau also nicht
den normalen kakao und backpulver weiche
butter etwas vanille zucker eine prise
salz und hier habe ich noch zartbitter
kuvertüre geschmolzen die lasse ich ein
wenig abkühlen in meine saubere und
fettfreie schüssel gebe ich eigelb mit
der prise salz und der hälfte des
zuckers nun wird das ganze vollständig
steif geschlagen bis eine richtig feste
masse entstanden ist
sobald dann die baiser masse schönweiß
und fest ist geben wir sie an die seite
und machen weiter mit den nächsten
zutaten hierfür geben wir die weiche
butter die habe ich bereits am vorabend
aus dem kühlschrank genommen
zusammen mit dem restlichen zucker und
dem vanillezucker in die rührschüssel
und rühren das so lange bis es hell
cremig ist
[Musik]
nach etwa zwei minuten gehen wir nach
und nach die eigelbe mit hinzu und wenn
sie so lange unter bis sie sich mit der
butter masse verbunden haben
anschließend geben wir die geschmolzener
und abgekühlte kuvertüre mit hinzu ich
habe sie etwa 10 bis 15 minuten abkühlen
lassen macht euch keine sorgen sie wird
dadurch nicht fest aber wichtig ist dass
wir sie nicht heiß mit zu masse geben
die kuvertüre hat sich inzwischen gut
mit der restlichen masse verbunden das
dauert auch gar nicht lange nur ein paar
sekunden und dann nehme ich hier noch
den rest des tages vom rand der schüssel
mit
nun geht es auch schon an die trockenen
zutaten die färöer ich vorher kurz
miteinander und gebe sie dann durch ein
sieb damit wir auch keine klümpchen im
teig haben
die trockenen zutaten werden dann im
teig noch mal gut eingerührt und sobald
sie sich verbunden haben geht es weiter
mit unserer baiser masse
die b&c masse heben wir dann in zwei bis
drei schritten vorsichtig mit unserem
teigs aber unter sobald die baiser masse
dann gut in den teig eingearbeitet wurde
geben wir sie in unsere mit backpapier
ausgelegte springform meine hat einen
durchmesser von 26 cm und in der
springform streiche ich den teig mit
einer winkel palette noch mal schön
glatt
jetzt wird der teig bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen
für 30 minuten gebacken
nach dem backen habe ich den schokoladen
teig vollständig auskühlen lassen und
kann ihn jetzt von der springform
entfernen
jetzt wird der boden einmal in der
hälfte durch geteilt ich nehme dafür am
allerliebsten maid orten säge
ihr könnt auch wenn ihr mögt ein großes
brotmesser mit dem wellenschliff nehmen
für die weitere verarbeitung benötigen
wir reichlich aprikosen konfitüre
nun müssen wir sie nur noch einmal
erhitzen entweder wie ich in der
mikrowelle dann ist aber die schüssel
sehr heiß also bitte vorsicht oder in
einem topf einmal zum kochen bringen
ich gebe das immer ganz gerne durch ein
sieb damit ich auch kein stückchen habe
und danach geht es auch schon weiter auf
den ersten tortenboden geben wir dann
drei bis vier esslöffel der aprikosen
konfitüre und verteilen sie gleichmäßig
[Musik]
nun geben wir unseren deckel darüber und
verteilen die restliche aprikosen
konfitüre darüber
[Musik]
an der stelle verteilen wir die
konfitüre auch an den seiten der
sachertorte damit sie auch von allen
seiten gut damit benetzt ist
[Musik]
jetzt muss die sachertorte für
mindestens eine stunde in den
kühlschrank damit die aprikosen
konfitüre schön trocknen kann
in der zwischenzeit zeige ich euch die
zutaten für die glasur
wir benötigen zartbitter kuvertüre sahne
und butter
nun geben wir alle zutaten in einen
kochtopf und lassen das auf mittlerer
stufe langsam erhitzen
[Musik]
sobald sich dann allmählich alle drei
zutaten miteinander verbinden ist die
schokoladenglasur auch schon fertig
damit die glasur nicht ganz so heiß auf
die torte kommt lasse ich sie fünf
minuten an der seite stehen nehme dann
meine torte aus dem kühlschrank und gebe
die glasur darüber
die leckere schokoladenglasur wird jetzt
nur noch auf der sachertorte verstrichen
von oben und von den seiten und am
besten funktioniert das mit einer
kleinen winkel palette
[Musik]
nach dem auskühlen ist die schöne
glänzende und schokoladige sachertorte
dann auch schon fertig zum servieren und
ihr könnt sie endlich genießen
[Musik]
hier zeige ich sie euch auch noch mal im
anschnitt die sachertorte ist total
schokoladig saftig und auch ein wenig
fruchtig wegen aprikosen konfitüre
sie hält sich übrigens vier bis fünf
tage frisch das heißt ihr könnt sie auch
mit gutem gewissen einige tage im voraus
zu bereiten und dann lasst ihr euch sie
einfach schmecken
ich bin gespannt was ihr zu sagen habt
und auch wieder mal auf eure fotos mit
dem hashtag iges kitchen auf instagram
die genauen mengenangaben findet ihr wie
immer unten in meiner infobox ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und sagt bis zum nächsten mal
auf die skizzen
[Musik]